this is an elementary school in Columbus
Ohio and inside of this school there was
a student named D wendy started school
here he was six years old
cute as a button with a smile that
bright in the entire room but after a
few months in school he became angry and
that smile faded he began to do things
like flip tables throw dust and chairs
yell at teachers stand in window sills
run in and out of the classroom and even
running out of the school
sometimes these fits of anger would put
the entire school into lockdown mode
until Dee could get himself back
together which could sometimes take over
an hour no one in the school knew how to
help dee I know this because I was the
principal at this school and what I
quickly and collectively learned with my
staff was that this situation was more
extreme than anything we had ever been
trained for every time a d-latch doll I
kept thinking to myself what did I miss
during my principal prep coursework what
am I supposed to do with a kid like Dee
and how am I gonna stop him from
impeding the learning of all the other
students and yet after we did everything
that we thought we knew such as talking
to Dee and taking away privileges and
parent phone calls home the only real
option we have left to do was to kick
him out and I knew that would not help
him this scenario is not unique to be
students all over the world are
struggling with their education and
though we didn't come up with a
fail-safe solution we did come up with a
simple idea that in order for kids like
Dee to not only survive in school
but to thrive we somehow had to figure
out a way to not only teach them how to
read and write but also how to help them
deal with and manage their own emotions
and in doing that we were able to move
our school from one of the lowest
performing schools in the state of Ohio
with an F rating all the way up to a C
in just a matter of a few years so it
might sound obvious right of course
teachers should be focused on the
emotional well-being of their kids but
in reality when you're in a classroom
full with 30 students and one of them's
throwing tables at you it's far easier
to exclude that child than to figure out
what's going on inside of his head but
what we learned about D and for kids
like D was that small changes can make
huge differences and it's possible to
start right now
you don't need bigger budgets or grand
strategic plans you simply need smarter
ways of thinking about what you have and
where you have it in education we tend
to always look outside the box for
answers and we rarely spend enough time
money and effort developing what we
already have inside the box and this is
how meaningful change can happen fast so
here's what I learned about D I was like
wanting to dig a little bit deeper to
figure out how he had become so angry
and what I learned was his father had
left the home and his mother was working
long shifts in order to support the
family which left no adult for D to
connect with Annie was in charge of
taking care of his younger brother when
he got home from school might I remind
you that B was six years old can't say
that I blame him for having some trouble
transitioning into the school
environment but yet we had to figure out
a way to help him with these big
emotions all while teaching him core
skills of reading and math and three
things helped us most first we had to
figure out where he was struggling the
most
and like most young kids arrival at
school can be a tough transition time as
they're moving from a less structured
home
to a more structured school environment
so what we did for D was we created a
calming area for him in our timeout room
which we had equipped with rocking
chairs and soft cushions and books and
we allowed D to go to this place in the
morning away from the other kids
allowing him time to transition back
into the school environment on his own
terms and as we began to learn more
about D we learned other strategies that
help them calm down for example D loved
to help younger students so we made him
a kindergarten helper and he went into
the kindergarten classroom and taught
students how to write their letters and
he was actually successful with a few of
them that the teacher was unable to
reach and believe it or not D actually
helped calm some of those kindergarten
students down signaling to us that the
influence of peers on behavior was far
greater than anything we adults could
ever do we used humor and song with him
yes I know it sounds really silly that
the principal and the teachers would
actually laugh with kids but you can
imagine the shock on DS face when the
principal is cracking a joke or singing
a song from the radio station which
almost always ended in a laugh
shortening the length of his outburst
and helping us to connect with him in
his world so I know some of you are like
it's really not practical to lay on this
kind of special treatment for every
student but we actually made it happen
because once we figured out the tools
and tactics that work for D our teachers
were able to roll that out and use them
with other students we began to
proactively address student behavior
instead of simply react to it
our teachers actually took time during
the lesson plan to teach kids how to
identify their feelings and appropriate
healthy coping strategies for dealing
with them such as counting to 10
grabbing a fidget spender or taking a
quick walk we incorporated brain breaks
throughout the day allowing kids to sing
songs do yoga poses and participate in
structured physical activities and for
those kids that struggle with sit
for long periods of time we invested in
flexible seating such as rocking chairs
and exercise bikes and even floor
elliptical machines allowing kids to
pedal underneath their desks these
changes encouraged kids to stay in the
classroom helping them to focus and
learn and when less kids are disrupting
all kids do better and here's the
magical thing it didn't cost us a whole
lot of extra money we simply fought
differently about what we had for
example every public school has an
instructional supply line an
instructional supply could be a book it
could be a whiteboard
it could be flexible seating it could be
a fitness center it could even be
painting the walls of a school a more
calming color allowing students to
thrive it's not that we didn't invest in
the academic tools obviously but we took
the social tools seriously - and the
results speak for themselves by taking
the emotional development of our kids
seriously and helping them manage their
emotions we saw huge growth in our
reading and math scores far exceeding
the one year of expected growth and out
scoring many schools with our same
demographic the second thing we did to
help our kids manage their emotions was
we use leverage as a not-so funded
public school we didn't have a support
staff to address the chaos that our kids
might be facing at home and we certainly
weren't trained or funded to address it
directly so we started to reach out to
local groups community agencies and even
the Ohio State University our
partnership with the Ohio State
University afforded us college students
not only studying education but also
school psychology and school social work
these students were paired with our
teachers to help our most struggling
students and everyone benefited because
our teachers got access to the latest
college-level thinking and those college
students got real-world life experiences
in the classroom our partnership with
our local Nationwide Children's Hospital
afforded us they're building us a health
clinic within our school providing
health and mental health resources for
our students and our kids benefited from
this two-hour absences continue to go
down and our kids have access to
counseling that they could access during
the school day and perhaps the biggest
change was not in D or in the kids at
all it was in the adults in the room
teachers are typically good at planning
for and delivering academic instruction
but when you throw in disruptive
behavior it can feel completely outside
of the scope of the job but by us taking
the emotional development of our kids
seriously we move from a philosophy of
exclusion you disrupt get out to one of
trust and respect it wasn't easy but we
felt at heart it was a positive way to
make change and I'm in all at the
teachers that took that leap with me as
part of our personal professional
development plan we studied the research
of dr. Bruce Perry and his research on
the effects of different childhood
experiences on the developing child
spring and what we learned was that some
of our students experiences such as an
absent parent chaotic home life poverty
and illness create real trauma on
developing brains yes trauma I know it's
a very strong word but it helped us to
reframe and understand the behaviors
that we were seeing and those difficult
home experiences created real
barbed-wire barriers to learning and we
had to figure out a way over it so our
teachers continued to practice with
lesson plans doing shorter lesson plans
with a single focus allowing kids to
engage and continue to incorporate these
movement breaks allowing kids to jump up
and down in class and dance for two
minutes straight because we learned that
taking breaks helps the learner retain
new information and might I add that the
cha-cha slide provides a perfect short
dance party
I saw teachers say what happened to you
instead of what's wrong with you or how
can I help you instead of get out and
this investment in our kids made huge
differences and we continue to see rises
in our academic scores I'm happy to say
that Wendy got the fourth grade he
rarely got into trouble he became a
leader in the school and this behavior
became contagious with other students
and we saw and felt our school climate
continue to improve making it a happy
and safe place not only for children but
for adults despite any outside influence
fast forward to today I now work with an
alternative education program with high
school students who struggle to function
in traditional high school setting I
recently reviewed some of their
histories many of them are 17 to 18
years old experimenting with drugs in
and out of the juvenile detention system
and expelled from school and what I
discovered was that many of them exhibit
the same behaviors that I saw in
six-year-old D so I can't help but
wonder if these kids would have learned
healthy coping strategies early on when
times get tough would they now be able
to survive in a regular high school I
can't say for sure but I have to tell
you I believe that it would have helped
and it's time for all of us to take the
social and emotional development of our
kids seriously the time is now for us to
step up and say what we need to do for
our kids if we teach kids how to read
and write and they graduate but yet they
don't know how to manage emotions
what will our communities look like I
tell people you can invest now or you
will pay later the time is now for us to
invest in our kids they're our future
citizens not just numbers that can or
cannot pass a test thank you
[Music]
[Applause]